A few weeks ago I had some questions about supplements for my functional doctor that my functional
doctor recommended and your response was a little hesitant maybe because I mixed up some
which supplements were for what problem. The NAAC and Resveratrol were to help my
EO, your methylation for the estrogen methylation protocol. So this person did a Dutch test that showed
E2 which is estradiol an increase in their methylated estradiol which they wanted to reduce.
And this doctor recommended some products. So we talked about that on the zoom call a few weeks ago.
And so you're clarifying that they're recommending the Resveratrol and the anacetyl cysteine
for that. And my only reservation for the anacetyl cysteine is that you know that is a glutathione
precursor and you know using it for a period of time to try to reduce that is fine but remember that
you could be possibly keeping a cancer alive by using anything that's a glutathione or glutathione
precursor just keep that in mind. Rival flavoured and phosphatidylcholine are to help lower the
whole cysteine levels along with B6 that I'm already taking. Okay that sounds fine too. So again
this is fine by only reservation with the anacetyl cysteine.